i'm just trying to trace the
constellation of where we started
so unlike us anyway brian what's your
pick for 80s origins
well why can't we why can't we stay
focused like when we talk about that
time when the guy from ferris bueller
was the captain of the enterprise bee
tom
what are some of the 80s movies
characters that you think need their own
origin story films
so as i was thinking about this it
occurred to me that there's this whole
family of characters that
sort of as far as i can tell they they
kind of emerged during the 80s and we
never got an explanation as to why that
was
uh i'm talking about your dirty dancings
your uh your foot loses your girl's just
gotta have i believe it's i believe it's
feet loose
your feet your feet's loose your
attorneys general eat lease
yeah
in all of these movies there is a uh
there's this one character that just
keeps popping up and that's the the dad
that does not want dancing to happen
[Laughter]
ooh the no dance dad the no dance dad
you got you got john lithgow in uh in
footloose and anyway the the character
just kind of keeps popping up and
they're all around the same age and i've
got this theory that
somewhere out there in like in the in
the creative abyss there is an it
chapter one where all of these dads were
friends as kids and dancing happened to
them in some kind of a horrible way and
now like 27 years later
they're being forced to
try and stop it before it reemerges and
becomes too powerful
the anti-dance crusade dads that's
yeah so
dirty dancing and footloose were the two
that i recall what was the third one you
said girls just want to have fun that
was the that's just the third one i feel
like it pops up a lot though right like
yeah generally if there's a movie where
somebody wants to do dancing they've got
a dad that's like there's someone who's
like no dancing's bad is there a is
there an anti-dance dad in flash dance
no idea
i don't think she's talking to her dad
by that point no i think she's she's
already working now
yeah that's true by day yeah that's
right
but only by day
she's talking to her dad
i don't know uh
yeah
so that's mine because then we get the
origin story of jerry orbach from dirty
dancing
a character we know almost nothing about
who is awesome
he hates dancing and he loves his
daughter
and he's a doctor yeah and he's a doctor
he loves his daughter but not so much
that he won't put her in the corner yeah
no he will put her in the corner and
he's married to uh emily gilmore from
gilbert
the guy said that nobody puts baby in a
corner but he was empirically wrong
because her dad had done it five minutes
earlier by the guy do you mean patrick
swayze yeah i forgot the character's
name johnny the character's name was
johnny patrick swayze
yeah it was also just patrick's ways i
was gonna say jack but i was close
i'd love her very closely
love her yeah nope
yeah yeah
you say that three times into a mirror
he just appears
if only
i wish i wish yeah come on bring him
back i suppose it'll be like sylvia
sylvia yeah
who's next with
nina what are some
movies characters that you want to see
origin movies made for
uh great question so my favorite 80s
movie by far is ferris bueller's day off
i think that's a lot of people's
favorite 80s movie
and there's a there's a lot of
characters in that that could have
origin stories i mean
sloane peterson is of like super
interesting when she appears on screen
but because everything's told through
you know ferris's perspective we don't
learn about her as much as you might
want i don't know if i need rooney's
backstory as much especially you know
considering but um
but the one the one that i actually went
with is i want a cameron origin story
because i love cameron he is such a
fully formed character you understand
everything about who he is from like
minute two of his time on screen like
you you immediately are like i get this
guy but i want to know more about like
his weird museum house about this car
situation i almost like i don't even
know if i wanted to be an origin story
but maybe i just want to see the
continuation of like cameron rebelling
against his dad
see continuation i'm 100 for but it
seems like an origin story of cameron is
just watching a kid get brow beaten for
but i also want but i also want like to
see where all his like hypochondria like
if he just sat in his room and like
looked through medical textbooks and was
like here are all the diseases i have
like i feel like this kid created a lot
of his own neuroses just by himself well
what about the day that what about the
day that ferris and cameron met right
that's a good one that's a lot better
than the weird dark like uh
terrifying thing that i'm describing
why they're friends right like how do
they how do these two very opposite
people thanks for bailing me out of that
ryan i really appreciate it you're so
welcome much like ferris probably bailed
cameron out of a lot of scrapes and part
of this is because i just like i i mean
this would never be possible but i just
love alan rock so much and he's one of
my favorite character actors
now it's just star trek crosstalk i'm so
sorry
[Laughter]
every show this happens
sorry anyway yeah okay brian helped me
with my um fledgling non-idea and made
it into a good idea which is the ferris
and cameron friendship origin story
because i actually thought that was
pretty great
i love that i i'm not against your
original idea either i just think it's
just because
anderson like it's just this weird kid
well that would have to be the director
wouldn't it slowly getting weirder yeah
like more afraid of everything maybe i
just identify with it way too much
i think we all do yeah maybe that god
i'm getting more excited about this plan
yeah you know what let's we can have
both why can't we have both let's live
in a world where we have both where we
have everything it could be him writing
in his journal about the day his whole
life went wrong when he met ferris
bueller
it's just like the whole thing's an
extended flashback well i was gonna say
say you wanted to work with that very
weird fan theory that ferris is made up
big camera tamron's he's imagining him
oh that could get dark yeah
yeah so i took a young sheldon situation
i assume that's what happens in young
sheldon right that's exciting
that's literally everybody is in big
bang theory is actually in his head
well i mean yeah i don't know why they
talk to him otherwise to be honest yeah
young sheldon has a snow globe and it's
full of all of these sitcoms you know
what i'm saying elsewhere because that
weird and dark about child fantasies
then why can't why can't ferris feel our
stories i like the idea that that
sheldon has a snow globe and inside is
johnny galecki
just creeping around
inside is um it's howard wallace yeah
he's like oh man simon
he says he says a simon hellberg
catchphrase i don't know i don't want it
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry i mean a
turtleneck yeah i don't know yeah is
that the catchphrase i'm in a turtleneck
it shouldn't be that's what happens
like i was really good in a net who saw
that coming yeah he was in um
what was the name of that movie with
meryl streep and she was a terrible
singer florence foster jenkins she was
amazing in that he was amazing so he's
amazing
and it actually made me kind of mad yeah
yeah i was like is that the guy from big
bang theory like what he's so good and
that's just like a weird french art
house film with marion coteau and adam
driver and also a puppet and then simon
hellberg being
really phenomenally good and i i took it
personally a little bit i was like this
feels not allowed i'm just trying to
trace the constellation of where we
started
so unlike us anyway brian what's your
pick for 80s origins
well why can't we why can't we stay
focused like when we talk about that
time when the guy from ferris bueller
was the captain of the enterprise bee
like i feel like there's some subtle
finger pointing going on from tom
and uh frankly i won't stand for it
um i'll go ahead and stand for it i'll
take the opposition view oh
so we have an article up on looper.com
called characters from 80s movies we
knew their own origin stories and there
were a number of really cool ideas in
here i'm gonna list a few of the ones
that i like uh but we won't go into too
much depth um you mentioned ferris
bueller uh that's on here
did we mention cameron in this one was
that the person that we mentioned in
this article
as i scroll down to the bottom of the
article
is he not even on here he's not no no
he's not that's we're going to cut this
whole section
so anyway
i told you i was going off menu i'm
going to list some of my favorites
um so cause i was gonna recommend i'm so
sorry i'm i'm scattered today i was
gonna recommend since we already talked
about dirty dancing
jennifer gray
yeah genie oh that would be great right
yeah what's what's this the origin of
her beef with ferris how'd that all come
about i'd like to see that origin story
man that was a good decade for jennifer
gray as a whole wasn't it
it was pretty much the only decade for
jennifer jennifer gray i don't know
she's married to uh agent coulson from
marvel so she's all right nope she's
okay yeah for her yeah goodbye for
everybody good for everyone yeah yeah
exactly going back to dirty dancing and
taking patrick swayze and jumping off
into roadhouse that's one of the entries
here james dalton his character from
roadhouse yeah we'd love to see an
origin story of of how his character
became such a a ba butt kicker you know
you know what i would love out of that
origin story actually
i would really appreciate that one uh
because i would like to find out if
roadhouse was satire or not i have not
been able to get a straight answer from
anybody
my entire life it's not was this
tongue-in-cheek like was this was this
adam west batman but nobody's smiling or
whatever oh the tongue the tongue was
was not in the cheek this is just i
don't know what i like roadhouse or that
time chris pratt described all of
roadhouse on parks and recreation
[Laughter]
so i'm bringing up again
other other characters we have on here
is doc brown from back to the future
which i think i would be interested to
see a doc brown origin story but i
almost feel like that might ruin some of
the have you seen that that isn't john
mulaney bit i believe where he's like
why is this disgraced scientist friend
just hanging around here
high school kid like since someone
explained this
that's another one it's very it's much
it's it's like cameron from the other
leg yeah and it makes sense because so
often like that
that's how you start a hero's journey
right you have the you have the
character who is uncomfortable and
things have not been going well for them
they're like you get the born loser and
then you get to watch them win for the
first time that's kind of who doc brown
is in the in that before he makes the
time machine right he's just this kooky
scientist that has never succeeded at
anything right and then he's he happens
to succeed at inventing time travel
right yeah so again this would just be
like this would just be decades of this
man failing at everything that he
touches
until eventually he believes in himself
so much that he makes a deal with
terrorists to buy plutonium
again that's super depressing it's like
a breakdown but also like
i don't know it's like breaking bad
meets imitation game like wood watch
actually
uh some other at the end like an
imitation game they could say and today
they call it a car
that's another computer anyway go on
brian uh a couple other good entries
here we got marion ravenwood from uh
yeah the first indiana jones movie that
would be came close to picking that that
was a good one you can cast charlotte
ritchie who uh is on the
11th season of taskmaster she's a
british actress and she looks a lot
like karen allen
so if you if you we'll put up a side by
side here so you can see that they do
look very similar so we've got we've got
the perfect person to cast perfect but
you could see her early adventures with
indy that could be interesting uh lando
calrissian is on here we get a little
bit of that over in the solo movie but
for reasons we don't need to go into
that's not really the greatest yeah but
one of the charac there's two there's
two entries on here that i responded to
a lot one is david lopan from big
trouble little china cool choice
big trouble little china is one of those
movies that i didn't see till uh
relatively recently in my life even
though it's been around since the 80s it
was a few years ago it was on netflix
and i i was like you know i've never
seen this movie i've heard the title a
million times why didn't i watch it and
i watched it and my mind exploded i was
like why is this the first time i've
seen this movie this is incredible right
i would love to see the origin story of
of david lopez i would love to see the
origin story of literally any of the
characters in this
any
you know just like
what's a kurt russell jack burton right
yeah like i want to know how this guy
became such a confident adventurer
despite being awful like all of his
adventures
just like like his adventures that led
him to the point here that like how did
jack burton become jack burton an
adventure he has the charisma of kurt
russell that's how just incredible
incredible help
and david lopan i want to know like how
did this guy become this this kingpin of
crime in in uh in uh san francisco i
want to know like how this this weird
magical underworld like grew in in this
area like i would be fascinated to learn
that's such a good one yeah it's it's
such an exciting concept to me that it's
it's it almost again it makes me mad
that i haven't seen it um
and the other one that i really liked
from the list was eddie valiant from uh
who framed roger rabbit yeah i love that
that was a really good one yeah hopping
off of doc brown from back to the future
now we're going uh christopher lloyd
over to our friend bob hoskins playing
eddie valiant now this is a great great
great great movie and i know that it's
like cliche to say that oh who framed
roger rabbit what a great movie like
everybody knows that yeah it's a truth
universally accepted that it's a good
movie but if you but if you haven't gone
back to see it in a while you're just
like you're you i was again i was blown
away i rewatched it pretty recently for
the first time in many years and i was
just like this movie is so incredibly
good and part of it right because this
guy eddie valiant is this fully formed
character and so what's great about
hopkins is such a pinch hitter i mean
super mario brothers is even good in
that
a movie that brian loves who i love
i
i think that i mean that's a whole other
show i think the super mario brothers
movie is extremely underrated the whole
cast
[Laughter]
brian did you prepare a powerpoint for
this for this episode
i've been waiting for someone to bring
up the supermarket oh now that you
mention it click click um
no funny i should say that but but
eddie valiant is this great character
who's haunted by his past his the tragic
loss of his brother yeah you could even
just have
like just one movie of him doing a case
with his brother it doesn't even have to
be the one where his red eyes and you're
just like them interacting with the
tunes of the time and just kind of
it's just who would you want to play a
younger eddie valiant is my
it's my hot seat question i never think
of the casting and i'm so mad
i'm trying to i mean chris pratt seems
like the natural choice right
chris pratt would actually be pretty he
would be pretty good
yeah was just trying to throw some mario
shade but yeah no it would actually kind
of work no he actually
kind of wouldn't
do that but it would work kind of well
i don't know why i don't know why jesse
plemons is popping into my head but he
he could do it he could be the brother
but here's
yeah like here's here's why it could
work with chris pratt or any like comedy
guy because there's this great photo
they pan over all the photos when we're
meeting eddie and he's asleep he's drunk
at his desk we're seeing the photos on
his desk we're learning about his
character one of the photos is him and
his brother as young kids with their dad
and they're dressed as clowns
right perfect it's like yeah that's and
that's how at the end right it's one of
those yeah payoff right at the end he
juggles he does the song and dance
everyone and if you're if you haven't
been paying attention you go how does
this guy know this whole like crazy
performance to get the weasels to laugh
themselves to death it's because he was
a clown so that would be kind of nicely
full circle from um guardians of the
galaxy where he uses a song from his
mom's mix to
distract ronan yeah
it's all there
chris pratt feels like too safe and
answer i feel like maybe oh you know who
would be good again more super mario
brothers stuff charlie day would be kind
of good he would be great
small
just the weird ice cream energy yeah
yeah
anytime i want things to be really off
the rails i'm like charlie day should be
in it like wouldn't you want to see
charlie day wearing a fedora
investigating crimes of the body you
didn't even need to finish that sentence
do you want to see charlie day's all i
needed to hear but yes i definitely want
to see him in a fedora solving crimes it
was even with cartoons it would be funny
with almost such a cool idea like do it
i want this i would love to see it as
like a tv series like yeah you don't
necessarily even have to be building up
to the big payoff where eddie valiant's
brother dies you could just do this like
adventure season
like a crime procedural but with
cartoons
yeah no that could be really fun it
writes itself
which network wants to pay us for this
idea i mean it would have to be disney
plus since they own the rights too from
roger okay well does disney plus want to
pay us for this idea is my immediate
follow-up question i mean i would love
it if they did but i'm sure that
when it comes out they'll be like oh no
that was long in development before you
said anything right that was a russo
brothers original yeah oh
man
it would be great though yeah oh no no
i'm changing my my answer what's his
name um um um uh you're a guy from
philly what's his name come on you're
good cooper bradley cooper my guy from
philly i wish um yeah he'd be perfect
young uh young eddie and then uh charlie
day could be the brother
nobody looks like young man is quite
like bradley cooper thanks for watching
please hit like and subscribe so you
don't miss a single video we love you
bye